i adore halloween it's my favorite
holiday
but the cast of superstore might like
even it even more than i do
each year the cast and crew grow hard on
their halloween episodes
and they're big favorites with the fans
of the show so
guess what here to talk spooky stories
with me
from superstore is none other than nico
santos
[Applause]
hi good morning oh my god i'm
freaking out i'm so excited you're here
thanks for having me i'm very excited
i'm here i'm trying to be a little quiet
because my boyfriend's still sleeping
um but yeah hi thanks for having me oh
that is really nice of you
that's very considerate um okay let's
get right in
you grew up in the philippines uh by the
way where in the philippines may i ask
manila philippines i grew up there so i
did not grow up with halloween it's not
really a thing in our country so
my first experience with halloween was
sort of like the crazy high school and
college parties which is a very
different experience than the kids grow
up here
um i love manila i've been there a few
times where did you go to college
yeah oh i i went to um southern oregon
university
okay so that's where you found halloween
yes oh i bet you did in oregon and you
brought some festive halloween news for
us
right i did i have a few stories for you
all right let's get
for you ready it's halloween headlines
[Applause]
just for you nico okay all right thank
you so much
okay our first story is the hottest
item for the season everybody's
decorating their houses for that
it's the 12-foot skeleton from home
depot yep
i mean you can't get you can't touch
this thing
no i mean it's i mean if you had this in
your home it would be super scary i mean
it's like your own security system
it's sold out everywhere it's been
reselling on ebay for like thirteen
hundred dollars
yeah um which you know you can get like
a designer bag or a twelve foot skeleton
which is great
um i think i would go through the
skeleton for sure
your word i'd go talk about skeletons
like my dream man he's
tall big bone cheekbones yeah he's he's
lovely you know we tried my mom actually
works at home depot
oh that's right and she couldn't get one
right
she couldn't get one she's been texting
me she's like
you know these are the only skeletons we
have left but they're not that big
they're very tiny
so our show tried to call home depot
as well and they were like thank you for
calling but
sorry guys so the business side of me
wants to just say to home depot with all
humility in the world maybe some more
next year
yeah i mean it was a surprise hit for
them they just didn't expect the demand
so yeah they need to wrap
it up well i love it i love it okay
now your next story is
the next story is i don't know if you're
ready for this it's very creepy
um they filmed this goat
in india walking on its hind legs oh you
can't even see that
oh it's so creepy oh my god i hate it so
much
oh my god you're like eric cunningham
from the news division
literally it freaks him out too i don't
know why
i'm totally into this like i feel like i
just want to have tea and walk alongside
it
well i feel like this goat was just like
you know what i'm done with 20 20s
korean i'm out of
here and just started walking out
totally
i mean it's so like human by the way
have you ever stared into a goat's eyes
that's weird i try not to because they
might steal my soul
but their
pupils are like rectangular rather than
circular it's totally different
i mean that's straight from the devil so
yeah no thank you
by the way that's what eric said that
it's like devil goat
um by the way okay your third story i'm
really into this
go ahead please okay the third story is
um this they have this event every year
uh in cape cod i believe
and it's witches uh people dressed up as
witches and they go uh paddle boarding
yeah and it's like super cute look at
that i mean adorbs
i love this story i love paddle boarding
i feel like this is the witch's um
equivalent of the x games
because they're not allowed to get wet
so this is how they get their thrills
their adrenaline rush
is that you know if they fall in that
water it's
they're gone for they're done
i love the stories that you have brought
to us nico i mean
i am a pop culture and news junkie and
getting to do this with you and seeing
the stories
that you thoughtfully curated for us
this halloween
is so awesome and superstar returns on
october 22nd
and i think everybody's gonna be so
happy to have it back
it's exactly what we need right now and
nico this was such a pleasure
thank you so much for coming on the news
[Applause]
[Music]